salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui petite sortie pêche à
leyment sur un coin qu'on n'a jamais
fait on ne sait pas ce qu'il peut y
avoir il ya des amis
donc oui je pêche plutôt sympa en
prévision ouais on attaque tout de suite
pêche à leyment dans le froid bon vous
allez voir avec la bouille de rasta
cette vidéo a été tournée il ya un petit
moment mais on s'était dit que c'était
intéressant de la partager avec vous
un petit truc là
une pile
une épaisseur non non non non c'est de
la merde
ouais avoir de faire à tout faire
alors de pêche nous tel buy
way sympa un beau vélo pour enfant moi
j'ai fait à l'heure
de l'orne
j'ai quelque chose encore
à
une clé au sein des bourses
et une pilule
ella crir est récupérable
6,6 en vrai oui à les rayures et seront
pas mal
oh oui bon celui-là je nie qu'elle
voit ça dans les fleurs et les filles
cru
ouh là là par contre gaffe aux bords en
métal sur toi tu roules tu remontes loin
ouais ouais
ouais pas si facile d'un gros truc à
moi ça vient ça vient aussi lourd
voilà ça a lâché
c'est vrai je me suis baladée dessus on
va finir par l'avoir à l'usure gerlach
portable du coup ça c'est un portable de
dealers probablement non
wells a récupéré la garde au sima
l'intérieur regardent
peut faire le jeu pour enfants avec les
étonnants votre attachement plus truc
parce que là on entre ici
ah oui
ou une cuillère
tu manges avec ce soit à
assumer
un temps fort le bloc suis pas bloqué je
suis pas bloqué
non ça va mais là on la déco l'été
ouais ouais on y va
tous nous as a lâché plus qu'en août ce
sera au départ
tout ça pour ça c'est une pierre
tout ça pour une cuillère
[Musique]
là franchement j'ai deux doigts de
plonger les gazons neymar on a dû passer
une demi-heure sans ce truc ouais mais
quand on voit les anciens ont fait c'est
du pur bonheur
junon annonce au nom non non ça ça vu sa
bulle non non je suis tu one internity
l'état
ça m'a saoulé du coup on va les
rechercher
adage bien tes cheveux
[Musique]
à temps mais en vrai attend attend d'y
aller
ségolène manquons du coup mais oui
attends quoi cette attente envoie le
mans
envolés - c'est à dire si on envoie les
manques tu suivant
les bonnes
[Musique]
affaires de turner pas pourrait
alors se soucie
t debout dessus
et tu
parles pas de prendre le palais a dit
[Musique]
elle est bonne non
[Rires]
et où
tu as la
[Musique]
mémoire et s'est déroulée la corde les
mois après si on peut faire vraiment un
au tour son rival à droite
non non mais on est foutu il es tu là
mes
rôles ont
fait un truc
ah ah ah
et oui c'est un moteur
du climat allez
c'est bon ça tient boutique bel bobine
ça c
est bien l attend peut-être le reste un
moteur
ouais vas-y
attention
et le piqué de péniches alors c'est pas
choper la
pâte en asie tient l'autre côté deux
ballons au nom de façon plus sûre le
conneries saloperie london donnant pas
comme ça
c'est moi qui tire en deuxième donc
à pinces à linge
simple
oui ça te va bien
ouais c'est bien aller ni qu'elle saura
pas si lourd ouais comme comme le pôle
attente alors un numéro de série je
pense pour ça qu'ils ont jetés à sa non
non non mange pas les moules parce qu'un
bon en tout neuf comme ça c'est une
belle trouvaille
même si le volant il est totalement
défoncés
[Musique]
fois c'est fait je pense il est comme ça
rouille
basta
tu la laisses
on espère que cette petite vidéo bien
tranquille vous a plu en tout cas rester
à l'affût la semaine prochaine en arrive
avec une vidéo très très lourde si vous
voulez nous soutenir n'hésitez pas à
déposer un petit pouce bleus et à vous
abonner pour ne pas louper la vidéo de
la semaine prochaine bon week-end à tous